Trascrizione: Giorgia Zanfardin
Revisore: Simona Donda
Quante volte avete sentito,
nell'ultimo periodo:
“Eh ma ormai non si può più dire nulla.
Una volta ci si faceva una risata,
adesso tutti a offendersi.”
Questo è un errore di ragionamento,
pensare che prima
non si offendesse nessuno.
Pensare, cioè, che se prima una cosa
non si vedeva, e adesso sì,
significa che quella cosa non c'era.
In realtà c'era eccome, c'è sempre stata,
è che prima non aveva
occasione di manifestarsi.
Mi scuso per quello che sto per dire:
sarò molto schietta,
ma solo perché voglio essere chiara.
“Frocio” non si doveva dire
neanche negli anni '80.
Così come “negro”, così come “puttana”.
Se la sensibilità su alcuni temi aumenta,
è perché adesso, finalmente,
si sentono le voci di quelle persone
che sensibili a quel tema
lo sono sempre state.
Una volta, le uniche voci che si sentivano
erano quelle di chi aveva il potere:
quindi, possiamo dircelo,
non le donne, non le persone nere,
non la comunità LGBT: lesbiche, gay,
bisessuali, transgender e altro.
Questo perché era chi aveva il potere
a decidere se e quando
accendere i microfoni,
quindi le voci che si sentivano
erano sempre le stesse.
Adesso, con Internet,
ognuno di noi ha un microfono,
ognuno di noi può potenzialmente
parlare a tutto il mondo.
Ecco allora che su Twitter
va in tendenza il pensiero
di una persona che non ha potere,
però ha il potere di dirlo.
Ecco che diventa virale un video
di una minoranza che dice:
“Le cose così non vanno bene”.
Ecco che un'azienda fa una pubblicità
sessista o omofoba o razzista e fallisce,
perché milioni di voci
che sussurrano che così non va bene,
fanno un baccano enorme
se vengono microfonate.
Qualcuno pensa che per evitare
certi scivoloni
sia sufficiente
conoscere le regole del gioco.
“Allora, questa parola
non la possiamo più dire,
e questo stereotipo
va smussato un pochino.
Qui ragazzi sono tutti maschi,
ci mettete una donna? Una qualsiasi.
Ecco se non è bianca meglio,
così siamo un po' inclusivi.
Dai ragazzi, lo sappiamo come funziona.”
Eppure, ciclicamente,
c'è qualcuno che ha potere,
che conosce queste regole del gioco,
che si ritrova comunque
ad offendere una minoranza.
E se va bene si scusa -
senza capire di preciso
per cosa debba scusarsi,
ma almeno si scusa.
Se va male, gioca la carta del
“Eh, ma non si può più dire niente”,
cercando di passare per la vittima.
Sapete perché accade?
Perché conoscere le regole del gioco
non è sufficiente,
perché le regole del gioco sono,
a loro volta, governate da altre regole.
Se vogliamo fare un passo avanti,
dobbiamo conoscere le tre regole
che stanno alla base
delle regole del gioco.
Regola numero uno:
"Se la cosa non riguarda te
in prima persona, non fai tu le regole".
Vale a dire che non è un bianco
a decidere se una cosa è razzista;
non è un eterosessuale
a decidere se una cosa è omofoba;
non è un uomo a decidere
se una cosa è sessista.
Mi è capitato più di una volta
di sentire alcuni amici miei, neri,
lamentarsi di cose che per me
erano assolutamente non problematiche.
“Hai visto la campagna
di raccolta fondi per l'Africa?
È così degradante.”
Il mio cervello andava in tilt.
"Come degradante?
È una campagna di raccolta fondi
per l'Africa, danno i soldi all'Africa!"
“Quella celebrity,
che continua a mettere foto su Instagram
di lei con i bambini neri nei villaggi,
quand'è che la smette?”
No scusa, ma come "Quand'è che la smette"?
Ma questa è piena di soldi,
potrebbe passare la sua vita in vacanza,
invece va lì ad aiutare,
e tu dici “Quand'è che la smette?”
È normale che questa
sia la prima reazione.
Che ci sembra di sentire
qualcosa fuori di testa.
In realtà lo è.
È fuori dalla nostra, di testa,
se siamo bianchi.
Per noi quelle cose sono positive,
quindi quando sentiamo
una persona nera lamentarsene,
è facile pensare che sia
troppo sensibile, addirittura ingrata.
Questo perché ci dimentichiamo
la regola numero uno:
se la cosa non riguarda noi in prima
persona, non facciamo noi le regole.
Non è un bianco a decidere
se una cosa è razzista
perché è difficile riconoscere
il razzismo se non ne sei vittima,
perché non sei allenato a vederlo.
Ci ho messo un po’, ma ho iniziato
a fidarmi di questa regola
e anziché dire “Tu sei matto”,
ho cominciato a chiedere "Perché?".
Perché la campagna di raccolta fondi
per l'Africa è degradante?
Perché la celebrity
che mette le foto su Instagram
di lei con i bambini neri nei villaggi,
dovrebbe smetterla?
La campagna di raccolta fondi per l'Africa
è degradante perché racconta l'Africa
sempre e solo in un modo,
cioè come un continente tutto uguale
dove non possono salvarsi da soli.
È degradante perché sfrutta il corpo nero
per muovere a compassione una persona
per quei due minuti che servono
per mandare un messaggino
e donare un euro;
ma non crea alcun cambiamento culturale.
Non fa progredire l'Africa,
e di certo non fa progredire noi.
La celebrity che mette su Instagram
le foto di lei con i bambini
neri nei villaggi
la deve smettere perché si sta
atteggiando a salvatrice bianca.
“Eccola: guardate questo angelo
sceso dal cielo per aiutare.
Che brava signora mia, guardi,
potrebbe essere ovunque invece è lì.”
Fa niente se non abbiamo
neanche idea di dove sia questo "lì",
e soprattutto fa niente
se non abbiamo la minima idea
di chi siano i professionisti locali,
che devono pur esserci.
Che si fanno il mazzo quotidianamente
per migliorare la situazione dall'interno
e che continueranno a farlo
anche quando i riflettori
se ne saranno andati,
perché i riflettori seguono lei, non loro.
Boom!
Quante cose a cui non avevo mai pensato!
Quante donne abbiamo bollato come frigide
perché non hanno riso
alla nostra battuta sconcia?
Quante persone della comunità LGBT
abbiamo chiuso nello stereotipo
di “troppo sensibile”
perché non sono andate al cinema
a vedere l'ennesimo film
che le usa come espedienti comici?
Pensate a quante cose
avremmo potuto imparare
se solo avessimo saputo prima
che le regole del gioco,
se il gioco non riguarda noi,
non le facciamo noi.
Se avessimo chiesto, perché?
Regola numero due:
"Se vuoi giocare, devi seguire le regole."
La cosa che mi ha fatto litigare
di più nella mia vita,
è la sequenza di +2 e +4
che partono ogni volta che si gioca a Uno.
Il gioco di carte, ce l'avete presente?
Io gioco un +2 e il mio avversario
deve pescare due carte.
Invece no: lui gioca un +2 a sua volta
e mi vuole far pescare quattro carte.
Ora, non lo puoi fare.
E non lo puoi fare
perché in ogni mazzo di carte di Uno
c'è un foglietto con delle regole.
Una delle regole dice
che se ti arriva un +2,
tu peschi due carte e salti il turno.
Non esiste che cominciamo
'sta catena di Sant'Antonio di +2 e +4,
non lo puoi fare.
E non voglio sentire
“Eh ma io gioco così”,
perché allora le regole,
cosa le fanno a fare?
E poi, anche ammesso di volerle cambiare -
che non capisco perché,
perché le regole le fa chi fa il gioco -
me lo devi proporre prima.
Non che durante tu decidi +2,
e io dovrei anche vederti dietro.
Fuori di metafora,
se incontriamo una persona
che fa parte della comunità LGBT
e usiamo il termine frocio,
non possiamo aspettarci
che questa reagisca bene.
Perché frocio è un insulto
e di base non va usato.
Alcuni miei amici gay
si chiamano frocio tra di loro.
All'inizio la cosa mi confondeva,
“È un problema solo se lo uso io?”
A parte che a qualcuno dà fastidio
anche detto all'interno della comunità,
ma comunque un conto è se è un ragazzo gay
a usare il termine “frocio”,
per depotenziarlo.
“Ah, tu volevi insultarmi
con quella parola?
Sprechi il tuo tempo,
perché mi ci chiamo già da solo.”
Un altro è se io, che non faccio parte
di quella comunità,
mi arrogo il diritto
di utilizzare quel termine
perché "I miei amici gay lo fanno"
o "Ai miei amici gay
non dà fastidio quando lo faccio".
Sì, anch'io a casa mia con mio papà
ho la regola che i +2 e +4 si sommano;
ma non per questo,
se gioco con qualcun altro,
parto dal presupposto che quella -
che è un'eccezione,
più che essere una nuova regola,
vada bene anche per lui.
Questo funziona anche in scala più grande.
Quando ad esempio si pensano
dei prodotti, film, canzoni
per la comunità LGBT
e si fanno in un certo modo.
Ecco, se la comunità LGBT ti dice
che quel modo non va bene,
non hai alternative al cambiarlo.
O meglio, l'alternativa c'è,
ed è trincerarsi dietro
la giustificazione, ormai abusata,
del “Ma io l'ho fatto in buona fede”.
Ecco, la buona fede non funziona
per una semplice ragione:
la regola numero tre.
"Le buone intenzioni
non sono sufficienti".
Questa è forse la regola
più difficile da digerire.
Perché se noi facciamo qualcosa
per un'altra persona,
non accettiamo che qualcuno ci dica
che quella cosa non va bene
o che addirittura sia controproducente
per la persona per cui
l'abbiamo fatta in prima battuta.
E questo, perché non ci è chiara
una differenza
che invece è centrale,
per comprendere questo discorso.
E cioè che intenzione ed effetto prodotto,
non sempre coincidono.
Immaginiamoci la scena.
Incontriamo un'amica
che non vediamo da diverso tempo
e le diciamo:
“Cavolo ma come ti vedo bene,
sei dimagrita tantissimo”.
E lei ci risponde:
“Sì, in effetti ho perso parecchio peso
perché è un periodo in cui
non sto particolarmente bene.
Anzi, speravo non si vedesse così tanto”.
Ahia.
La nostra intenzione era quella
di farle un complimento,
perché dire “sei dimagrita” è ancora
considerato un complimento -
ci vorrebbe un TED Talk a parte.
L'effetto prodotto -
(Applausi)
L'effetto prodotto è un disastro.
Questo fa di noi dei mostri sadici
che amano far soffrire il prossimo?
Ma certo che no.
Ma il fatto che noi non volessimo
farla soffrire non è sufficiente,
tant'è vero che lei
sta soffrendo comunque.
Certo, noi non lo sapevamo,
non è colpa nostra.
Però rimane una nostra responsabilità,
perché siamo stati noi a dire quella cosa,
anche se in buona fede.
Come ne usciamo?
Scusandoci.
Dicendole che davvero non volevamo
farle riaffiorare emozioni negative.
Anzi, se c'è qualcosa che possiamo fare
per stemperare un po’ la tensione,
lo facciamo volentieri - davvero, scusa.
La stessa cosa accade quando un uomo,
nel tentativo di fare
un complimento a una donna,
finisce per avere invece
un atteggiamento molesto.
Giusto l'altro giorno guardavo
i messaggi sul mio Instagram.
Ne ho trovato uno di un ragazzo
che mi diceva quanto fossi bella,
e quanto gli piacessero
le mie labbra carnose.
Ora, io non conosco
le intenzioni di questo ragazzo.
Voglio essere ottimista, pensare che fosse
il suo tentativo di farmi un complimento.
Ciononostante, io mi sono
sentita molto a disagio.
Era mattina, avevo appena
preso in mano il telefono,
la prima cosa che ho dovuto vedere
è stato questo messaggio
da parte di uno sconosciuto.
L'ho vissuta veramente
come un'invasione del mio privato.
Ma perché me lo stai dicendo?
Ma perché pensi che mi interessi?”
Se siete uomini,
parlate con le donne della vostra vita.
Avranno tutte - tutte -
una storia simile da raccontarvi.
E moltissime di loro
utilizzeranno le stesse parole:
“Mi sono sentita sporca, in colpa,
responsabile, piena di vergogna”.
Capite che le buone
intenzioni non bastano?
Se una donna vi dice:
“Io mi sono sentita a disagio”,
il vostro “Ma io non volevo” ha senso solo
se volete far sapere la vostra intenzione,
non se pensate che questo
vi renda immuni alle critiche.
Eppure, ogni volta che accadono
scivoloni del genere
nel pubblico e nel privato,
la tiritera è sempre la stessa.
“Io l'ho fatto in buona fede.
Quindi se tu l'hai vissuta male,
il problema è tuo,
che sei troppo sensibile.”
Ecco, no.
Se vuoi fare qualcosa di utile
per un'altra persona,
devi partire dal presupposto
che lei sappia meglio di te
come si possa fare.
Devi fidarti di quello che ti dice.
E se sbagli, ed è umano sbagliare,
devi chiedere scusa e riprovare.
Se ti interessa giocare a questo gioco.
Se no, puoi sempre proporne un altro!
Uno in cui le regole le fai solo tu,
le cambi a tuo piacimento,
e se non vinci, annulli la partita.
Poi però, devi trovare qualcuno
disposto a giocare con te.
Buona fortuna.
Grazie.
(Applausi)